plus vite plus haut plus fort c'est la
devise olympique le titre suprême sur
les jeux olympiques
bien sûr qu'on reste de l'or olympique
c'est un objectif de carrière
l'objectif même de vie on a envie
d'aller au bout de soi même je me
donnerais bien sûr tous les moyens pour
y arriver
l'objectif c'est d'y faire quelque chose
pas que de participer à tellement
d'étapes avant il ya tellement de choses
avant cette année elle va être longue
les jo de rio c'est dans moins d'un an
la france compte 6500 sportifs de haut
niveau
la plupart sont amateurs amateurs et
souvent précaires près de 40% d'entre
eux vivent avec moins de 500 euros par
mois
beaucoup ne sont pas salariés ils n'ont
pas de contrat avec le club ni
d'assurance spécifiques à leur métier
une proposition de loi examiné cet
automne par le parlement vise à mieux
protéger le statut des sportifs il est
primordial qu enfin la france
reconnaisse le rôle de ces sportifs de
haut niveau et que ce rôle
j'allais dire sera gravé dans le marbre
de la loi au sénat
c'est michel savin qui défend le texte
il faut trouver l'équilibré entre les
objectifs sportifs et je comprends que
les entraîneurs ils sont payés par les
fédérations e sur là pour faire de la
médaille mais aussi il faut prendre en
compte l'intérêt du sportif bien sûr
avant le temps vous préparer ces
compétitions mais aussi avoir un minimum
de temps pour préparer sa reconversion
je
jean
150 kilos sur le dos
mais dix de plus 60 c'est encore loin de
son record
230 kg soit une part de folie aussi
parce que ça engendre quand même des
risques
après ça je vous cache pas qu'on peut
avoir mal au dos être fatigué quoi tout
simplement michael d'almeida n'est pas
haltérophiles mes coureurs cyclistes sur
piste
là on en retrouve assez vite là
aujourd'hui chercher le petit détail qui
peut faire la diff sa part beaucoup
d'exigence
c'est beaucoup de moments de contraintes
et difficultés pour finalement quand ça
se passe bien avoir une médaille autour
du cou
alors pendant cinq mois des médailles
michael d'almeida on a des dizaines
champion du monde cette année
vice-champion olympique en 2012 et
pourtant malgré ce palmarès
il n'a pas le train de vie d'une star
comme on s'imagine sportifs de haut
niveau professionnel ou quoi ce sont mes
revenus parce qu'on entend parler comme
ça lui des footballeurs des tennismans
mais pour donner un ordre d'idée j'ai
envie de dire que chez nous les mieux
rémunérés sont pas loin du soin le
cyclisme a beau être son métier il n'est
pas professionnel être à la fois
amateurs et de haut niveau c'est tout le
paradoxe de ces sportifs
nous semaine type d'entraînement sont
entre 25 et 30 heures d'entraînement
donc à côté il n'y a rien du tout et je
parle d'entraînement je parle pas de la
récupération politique comme des
professionnels on fonctionne comme des
professionnels malgré qu'on statue sur
les amateurs et professionnels michael
d'almeida est loin d'être le seul dans
ce cas
sur 6500 sportifs de haut niveau
quelques centaines seulement sont
professionnels l'union sportive de
créteil en banlieue parisienne
un club qui compte dix de ces sportifs
de haut niveau
ancien ou nouveau gloires passées ou à
venir
il trône tous dans la salle des
portraits
parmi eux michael d'almeida le cycliste
week-end il est en contrat de
prestations images c'est d'autres
contrats de prestations de services il
était auparavant salariés et puis depuis
2012 ont fait le choix de passer un
ensemble de sportifs en droit images
le contrat d'image un contrat où le
sportif s'engage à faire la promotion de
son club moyennant rémunération peu
d'obligations mais un contrat précaire
car à la différence d'un cdd ou d'un cdi
il n'y a pas de cotisation à l'assurance
chômage à la sécurité sociale ou encore
à la retraite des charges sociales que
le club ne veut pas ou ne peut pas payer
les spurs ne s'entraîne pas du tout ici
enfin jeu des pronos michael d'almeida
et s'entraîne à 100 content enfin voilà
on l'a pas sous la main donc moi que
signent un cdd avec quelqu'un je crée
des obligations réciproques qu'elles
vont elles être dans ce cadre là alors
qu'on n'ait pas le pouvoir de voile a le
pouvoir de direction la page sur champ
michael en clair le club renvoie la
balle à la fédération française de
cyclisme qui gère l'entraînement de
l'équipe de france
une fédération qui n'est pas assez riche
pour salarier ces sportifs de haut
niveau
sécuriser une bonne fois pour toutes le
statut de l'athlète de haut niveau en
tant que professionnel elle rentrée sous
un contrat fédéral serait pourrait
paraître la meilleure des solutions
aujourd'hui encore une fois les
fédérations je rappelle quand même socle
associatif loi de 1901 sont pas encore
on n'ont pas encore la capacité
budgétaire de pouvoir fonctionner sous
ce système là pour essayer de régler ce
problème
le parlement a créé un nouvel outil un
cdd de 12 mois sur une saison l'objectif
c'était d'éviter certaines situations
qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui ou des
sportifs signe dans des clubs avec une
durée le contrat qui se limitait la
durée de la de l'activité championnat et
se retrouve les trois quatre mois
suivants inscrits au chômage en
attendant de renouveler leur contrat
au niveau des clubs pour les
parlementaires la balle est désormais
dans le camp des fédérations et des
clubs pour s'emparer de ce nouveau
contrat
et
la carrière d'un sportif ne tient qu'à
un fil et une blessure suffit parfois à
le casser
ce centre de rééducation près de bayonne
remet sur pied ces grands blessés en
juillet dernier véronique mang a gagné
le titre de championne de france du 100
m et une blessure à la cuisse gauche à
quelques mètres seulement de l'arrivée
ça va très très vite on n'a même pas le
temps de dire oh la la qu'est ce qui se
passe donc l'obsession c'est de terminer
la course et je voulais vraiment pas
m'arrêter quoi c'est surtout ça donc il
fallait que j'aille au bout de mon
effort et que je me batte jusqu'au bout
une blessure qui l'obligent à rester
quelques semaines dans ce centre de
rééducation
une frustration à surmonter alors que
les jeux olympiques approchent
l'événement à boîte dans 11 12 - lyon 5
dans le très haut niveau le temps passe
très vite donc déjà juste après mon
opération j'étais déjà dans les jeux
j'étais déjà dans ma préparation en fait
pas du tout à l'abri d'un nouvel
accident musculaire et c'est repartir à
zéro avec le moral repart à zéro et
c'est souvent problématique
le problème de base super
dans ce centre de rééducation
une journée de soins avec hébergement
août plus de 200 euros tu fais honte
routine et après tu travailles sur
quatre
tout est pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale
encore faut-il pouvoir en bénéficier
l'athlétisme est traumatisante donc
énormément de blessures et c'est vrai
que cette année quand j'ai été blessé
donc mon club m'a permis donc avec
l'assurance du club de pouvoir donc
justifier des soins que j'ai pu
pratiquer dont je vais envoyer des
documents sur les factures sur les frais
d'opération des chirurgies donc c'est
très important ce constant sportive de
haut niveau et ça permet justement de
rebondir dans les meilleures conditions
véronique mang fait figure d'exception
car la plupart des sportifs n'ont pas
d'assurance liées à leur club
faute de contrat ils ne cotisent pas la
sécurité sociale
alors pour en bénéficier beaucoup
s'inscrivent à l'université
plus de 60% des athlètes de haut niveau
ont le statut d'étudiant
l'état veut mettre fin à ces disparités
et va donner à tous les sportifs une
couverture sociale
c'est l'un des points forts de la
proposition de loi leur statut de haut
niveau leur permettra désormais
d'accéder à une couverture dit accidents
du travail maladies professionnelles
on peut pas demander à des sorties de
s'engager comme ils le font en termes
d'investissements sur le sur un seul
entraînement sur les compétitions sans
avoir la garantie d'être devant une
certaine protection en cas d'accident
n'a rencontré des jeunes et des jeunes
sportifs qui suit un accident seront
trouvés seuls démunies et sans aucune
perspective c'est pas normal
en plus de cette couverture sociale les
fédérations auront aussi pour obligation
de souscrire à des complémentaires santé
pour leurs sportifs pour tout un
ensemble de sport il s'agit
effectivement d'une simple
régularisation il s'agit d'une véritable
généralisation mais qui va véritablement
asseoir la situation de ces sportifs et
qui va j'en suis persuadé améliorer les
conditions de sérénité du pratiquant la
machine est lancée
je suis pas ici pour pour vous donner
des leçons à vous les jeunes vous
raconter un moment de vie enfin 30
besoin de vie des blessures raphaël
poulain ancien rugbyman du stade
français on a eu beaucoup et partout il
ya cette épaule l'équipe est assez le
début je me retrouve avec la coiffe des
rotateurs péter le truc qui arrive
jamais à personne sauf à la coiffe du
rotateur il a dû arrêter sa carrière à
25 ans seulement elle voit toutes ces
blessures six opérations à 6 ans
je suis senti victime du rugby et du
belge ait eu des comportements aussi
d'evian parce que j'avais l'impression
d'en avoir pris plein la gueule
raphaël poulain traverse alors une phase
de dépression
drogue alcool conduite dangereuse il lui
faudra sept ans pour retrouver un peu de
sérénité
aujourd'hui il donne des conférences
pour sensibiliser les sportifs il me
parle du paraître
c'est énormément de retour de deux
joueurs blessés de joueurs en fin de
carrière des personnes qui ont fait des
burn out et qui sont qui sont contents
d'avoir un autre son de cloche est
acquis sentent moins seuls en fait pour
éviter les carrières brisées
le monde du sport s'interroge sur la
reconversion professionnelle 15 octobre
2015 à doha au qatar tony yoka 23 ans
est en finale des championnats du monde
des super lourds
trois round de trois minutes plus tard
c'est le sacre
quelques jours plus tard retour à la
salle d'entraînement
grâce à son titre de champion du monde
il est d'emblée qualifie pour les jo de
rio il remonte sur le ring et ne pensent
désormais qu'à ça
forcément nous puis j'ai commencé la
boxe je regarde mes idoles métallique a
été champion olympique knox lewinsky été
champion olympique
tous ces grands boxeurs ont été surpris
à pic pour avoir un semblant de carrière
comme un jeu trop forcément passer par
là sa fiancée le suit de très près et
pour cause elle et boxeuses vice
championne d'europe mais aussi
ingénieurs fois légers contre super
lourd ils n'ont pas du tout le même plan
de carrière je prenne encore trois kilos
offert un concert que je perds pas de
poids elle faut qu'elle fasse ce qu'elle
prenne pas de points donc c'est
compliqué dans le choix des menus à mais
n'ont pas la même ambition proférées le
sportif dans mes ambitions sont beaucoup
plus sportif professionnel
je ne sais pas 2
la boxe mon travail donc voilà c'est en
fonction de chacun sans fondé des choix
éviter de chacun tous deux viennent de
l'insep l'institut national du sport
ici plus de 600 jeunes sont formés dans
28 disciplines différentes
c'est la plus grande fabrique à
champions olympiques l'insep a créé la
notion de double carrière une carrière
de sportif et une carrière
professionnelle pour préparer l'avenir
si tony yoka se concentre sur le sport
une petite voix est là pour lui rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas que la boxe dans la ville
un peu ramé derrière toi xavier c'est
pas lui qui l'a réveillé un matin froid
les au bac
laurence blondel est la référente de son
suivi socio professionnelles il y a deux
ans elle a poussé à passer son bac ou
les sensibilisons et nous faisons en
sorte avec les fédérations qu' il y a un
certain continuum mais c'est pas en
parallèle d'une carrière sportive
c'était très compliqué de gérer parce
que je sortait tout juste du junior je
vais me préparer une tête de brahim
asloum beaucoup d'exposition médiatique
au goût de forcément les cheveux passés
seniors les entraînements c'était
beaucoup plus dur avec compétition était
plus relevé bancaire augmente j'arrivais
pas à concilier les deux sur cette
affaire
difficile pour un sportif de mener une
double carrière surtout quand les
entraîneurs mettent la pression pour
décrocher une médaille
le sportif à un moment donné peut se
retrouver dans une situation un petit
peu schizophrénique de se dire il faut
que je fasse le maximum pour la
performance et mon entraîneur de toute
façon ne me laisse pas le choix et en
même temps qui va se préoccuper de ma
situation au futur si moi même je ne
peux pas le prendre en compte pour
changer les comportements
la proposition de loi veut que toutes
les fédérations est désormais un
référent pour le suivi
socioprofessionnel une personne clé qui
prennent en main la double carrière de
chaque sportif les fédérations nous
devra uniquement halte là pour
recueillir les titres et puis et ne pas
s'occuper et suivre la carrière d'un
sportif de haut niveau tels que des
familles se disent est ce que
j'encourage mon enfant ma fille mon
garçon à faire du sport de haut niveau
parce que derrière caisse
professionnellement qu'est ce qu'il va
faire le sportif de haut niveau a peu de
temps pour mener des études
entre les compétitions le plus souvent à
l'étranger et les entraînements dans des
clubs parfois éloignés du domicile
suivre un cursus classique est
généralement un casse tête
une seule solution la formation à
distance
dans son étui léa palermo n'emporte pas
seulement sa raquette de badminton mais
aussi son ordinateur portable
entre midi et deux pendant sa pause
déjeuner elle file à la bibliothèque
pour réviser ses cours de management
bien sûr mon espace perso la plupart des
professeurs mettent en ligne des partis
pour qu'on assimile le court il ya
toujours des exercices et derrière où ça
prend souvent la forme de skype
collectif pour pour voir si on a bien
compris la chose le le prof est avec
nous nous explique le centre de
formation est à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de là à l'école de management
de grenoble
le sénateur michel savin visite
aujourd'hui cette structure on a
peut-être 90% des profs qui ne viennent
jamais à l'école pour suivre nos
sportifs l'avantagent du e-learning pour
une école également ses bas de
dématérialiser la salle de cours
concrètement là commence comment ça
fonctionne et contrôler ces jeunes qui
voici travail opa sur la plate forme on
peut vite vous voyez qu'un élève qui
commence à décrocher une alerte
en revanche la formation ne peut pas
délivrer de conventions de stage
pour cela il faut que les étudiants
soient présents physiquement 200 heures
aux classes une obligation de
l'éducation nationale
la formation distance est quelque chose
qui colle parfaitement au par rapport au
profil des sportifs de haut niveau donc
il faut l'éducation nationale le
printemps qu'on équipe à des contraintes
qui veut dire oui mais attendez vous
faire ça en temps beurre autant de jours
de présence ça c'est pas possible
à défaut d'avoir pu introduire une
mesure dans la proposition de loi les
parlementaires souhaitent que le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
généralise pas décret ces formations à
distance
à orléans c'est la coupe du monde de
sabre féminin
une trentaine de pays sont représentés
avec quatre françaises n'ont cécilia
berder vice championne du monde après
quelques matchs remporté facilement
c'est si la tombe sur une lame plus
affûtés
m
à aucun moment jean cras
vraiment un jeu
enfin ça c'est évident qu'ils ont des
fêtes c'est mal fait mal au coeur selon
le chantre peu mal aux tripes alors
comprendre falloir analyser analyser et
conseillers cécilia berder en a fait son
métier depuis trois mois elle est
également chroniqueuse à france info
france info
et on retrouve notre vice championne du
monde d'escrimé bonjour cécilia berder
bonjour aujourd'hui comment faire face à
la critique
et oui jérôme la critique on ne peut pas
y échapper avec importe notre métier
notre passion notre rang social toute
notre vie on sera sous les feux de la
critique les scream ses one shot
ça veut dire que tu as perdu tu peux la
douche elle est là bas voilà là j'ai
cette chance de me dire que si jamais je
me trompe je peux réenregistrer mets
typiquement ça m'agace je veux pas ré
enregistrer ses je me mets en mode j'ai
qu'une chance et critique vraiment pour
devenir journaliste elle a passé un
master dans une école parisienne
un diplôme qui lui donne une crédibilité
professionnelle critique donc à tous mes
critiques merci pour l'aide et merci
pour l'intérêt que vous me portez l'âme
olympique tous les samedis sur france
info avec cécilia berder merci les
journalistes donc nous on profite de de
son savoir faire de deux journalistes
puisque la voilà un diplôme est là elle
a des connaissances en la matière et on
profite aussi du fait qu'elles soient
sportifs de haut niveau et ce mariage là
permet d'avoir ces conseils sont des
conseils simples mais qui s'appuie sur
une légitimité sur une expérience qui
est celle d'une sportive de haut niveau
pour intégrer france info cécilia berder
a signé une convention d'insertion
professionnelle une convention
spécifique aux sportifs de haut niveau
qui lui permet d'aménager son temps de
travail
c'est ce parti n'a pas beaucoup de
pauses voilà ça va 2h30 d'assaut l'après
midi ça me passe tout seul synchronique
lui pro 10 heures par semaine ce qui lui
laisse 30 heures d'entraînement c'est
clair que quand je suis en compétition
je pense très peu à francin fois j'ai
même beaucoup de mal à écrire mes
chroniques et tout ça c'est de
l'organisation ça veut dire que la
semaine qui précède je vais rejouer je
suis en écrire deux parce que comme
homme quand je suis en compétition mon
esprit n'est pas vraiment à l'écriture
malgré son emploi du temps chargé
cécilia veut encore et toujours remporté
des médailles
son entraîneur dai sur elle il ne s'est
pas opposé à ce qu'elles trouvent du
travail faut un juste milieu il faut
quand même beaucoup de temps pour
fonctionner ça c'est sûr pour progresser
surtout dans les jeunes années c'est là
où les personnes en général font leurs
études et c'est là où elles n'ont pas
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de fatigue
mais moi je reste persuadé que avoir
quelque chose qui dédramatise les 150
touche qu'on prend à chaque entraînement
qui sont autant de petites défaites car
en moins fragile
cécilia vit en banlieue parisienne dans
un studio d'une seule grande pièce
exactement un balcon au-dessus sain et
un duplex grandes terrasses piscines
piscine après mathieu c'est son club qui
lui paie le loyer
elle reçoit aussi des primes en fonction
de ses résultats sportifs mais le
contrat avec radio france lui garantit
500 euros par mois
un sérieux coup de pouce à 500 euros
mois je vais loin que ça
tous les courses tous les noms c'est un
vrai plus
clairement c'est une bouffée d'art mais
j'ai jamais été très attiré par l'argent
et je vois là c'est un enrichissement
intellectuel et ça ça vaut tout l'or du
monde
vraiment seulement un sportif sur dix
est en convention d'insertion
professionnelle et pourtant ce contrat
permet aussi de cotiser à la sécurité
sociale et l assurance chômage de sortir
d'une forme de précarité les fois en
fait ce qui est le plus compliqué c'est
qu'on arrive dans les choses
administratives et on nous demande quel
est votre statut et jeudi bâché sportifs
et leur répondre ben moi aussi je suis
sportive
oui mais du coup j'en faisais beaucoup
quand même 10 par la moule si j'en fais
beaucoup bon quel est mon statut chez
soi finalement à la ceux qui sont
prompts à lever la main
à défaut de leur donner un véritable
statut la loi permet de mieux protéger
les sportifs de haut niveau
eh bien il ya unanimité sur la loi
félicitations à tous
une unanimité assez rare pour être
souligné les parlementaires ont
travaillé vite pour que les athlètes
puissent aborder les futurs jeux
olympiques dans de meilleures conditions
quand les champions tricolores dépasse
les couleurs partisanes